how different of a war
is 2034 going to be than what we expect
is it anything out of the ordinary
in your mind imagination in your mind
that you say these are a couple things
that's going to happen that nobody's
probably paying attention to today
i think it's important to point out like
2034 is a
cautionary tale it's not a predictive of
course
in so much as we're not trying to
predict the exact technology but we're
trying to show like this these are the
trends and you hit the evolution of war
so the one thing you always see is that
you know one technology kind of
overtakes
another technology and so oftentimes as
americans
we're sitting here and we're constantly
trying to like refine our technology and
we're spending all this money on new
aircraft carriers and on new jets
uh and fighter planes but we're not
asking ourselves the questions like is
this the right technology
to be investing in and you see that in
2034 there's a massive cyber attack
at the beginning of the book and what
that cyber attack does is it acts as a
level a leveler
so suddenly all these very high-tech
platforms we have
they don't work like you can't turn them
on
so without spoiling anything in the book
i would tell you like when you meet
wedge right he is flying this
state-of-the-art
f-35 joint strike fighter that doesn't
work
the last time you see wedge he is
piloting a generation one
f-18 hornet built like circa 1990 uh on
his final mission it's got no technology
in it
and so thematically one of the the
issues the book
wrestles with is how does technology
work in a war how do we advan take
advantage of technology and then have to
sometimes
use all technologies to outsmart our
adversary
essentially are you saying that the
modern technology is easier to hack into
and tap into than the old technology
yeah it is and sometimes the way you
defeat technology is without technology
can i give you an historical example
yeah
so like um i'm a history book one of the
one of my favorite battles i've studied
is the battle of agincourt
which was fought in 1415 it was made
famous by
william shakespeare in the play henry v
and at that battle basically
a british force had invaded france they
were at the end of their supply lines
uh ill-equipped trying to get back to
england
strung out when the entire french army
assembled against them this is like the
cream of the french
medieval nobility and they were decked
out
on the battlefield of agincourt the
french with what was the most
state-of-the-art technology at the time
and that technology was plate armor
they figured out how to fold steel into
plates to make these knights like
unstoppable so the french knights come
out there with their very expensive
technologically state-of-the-art plate
armor it rains the night before on that
field
and they're going to go destroy this
ill-equipped smaller english army
they go and charge across this field and
they kind of get bogged down in the mud
because their
their armor is so damn heavy and the
friend and the english
have a totally different technology that
is far less
far less expensive um and that's the
longbow
and they shower down arrows on the
french knights and just slaughter them
it's one of the greatest french military
defeats of all times
that is an example of yeah you might
have the most state of the art
technology
in your plate armor or in your f-35
or your ford class aircraft carrier but
it's the wrong technology for the battle
you're about to fight
so if you like this sort of short club
from an interview i did click over here
to watch the entire
interview and please don't forget to
subscribe to the channel
take care everybody bye
you